Let's take a deeper look at Maslow's Hierarchy of Needs, and that's the need to
belong. Humans have a need for social contact and belonging, and this is both
powerful and universal. Indeed, as we've said throughout the course, humans are
social creatures and we need interaction. Perhaps remember the lesson on
development with Terry Harlow and his research with the baby monkeys. Those
monkeys needed contact comfort, and they chose among them the most resemble
their own over the
[UNKNOWN]
mother, even though she had the food. Now, we too as humans have a need for
others in order to thrive, and this need for social contact and belongingness
is called the need for affiliation.